the body our children our number Jian
Xiu Jie Zhi Jing Fei Panda joy years up
the conchita oriental so quick we are
devastated and we are very troubled
because Beijing Beijing winning the
Olympic Games is sends the wrong message
to the wrong people at the wrong time
activists and lawyers had been locked up
independent media has been shut down and
the Great Firewall of China the internet
censorship that the country is so famous
for it's worse than ever it's time for
the International Olympic Committee and
the Olympic movement to insist that
China play by the rules we don't want to
see another Olympics tarnished by ugly
human rights abuses